alright guys welcome to the podcast
thanks Frank how's it going great good
Amy you are a founder coach I think a
lot of people don't know what coaching
actually is so maybe you could explain
it yeah that's actually a great question
because what coaching is depends a lot
on who the coach is and what their
expertise is and what their experience
has been so coaching in its most simple
term is a supportive relationship and
it's a supportive relationship that
helps people usually founders or execs
like managers resolve problems that
they're experiencing in their life so I
think some people might be familiar with
therapy and maybe have even done it
before how would you differentiate it
from coaching therapy is a relationship
that uses that relationship to affect
change whereas coaching is using the
coach's own life experience to affect
change they're both really similar
coaches often use their relationship
with the client as information to help
them understand the client in order to
better serve their needs but therapy is
almost all that it's all about the
client the clients relationships the
clients marriage friendships family all
that stuff whereas coaching is the
client and their work and their eating
habits and this that or the other that's
not all the relationship another big
difference actually is the credentialing
process so in therapy
for example I had to go to grad school I
had to get a masters degree and then
have 3,000 supervised hours before even
being able to apply to take the
licensing exam so that's five years of
my life whereas with coaching one day I
decided I'm gonna be a coach okay and
that's that's really the difference in
you can imagine the different types of
people for example that would opt into
one like career path versus the other
okay and so we've kind of outlined a few
of the most common problems startups
have here and so I think what could be
most helpful to people is we're just
gonna talk about the problems and then
we can outline the symptoms talked about
a couple examples and just go from there
okay so what is the most common problem
you see startups having the most common
problem I think that I see my
have is an inability to have difficult
conversations because their emotions get
in the way and or an inability to even
pinpoint the actual problem that they're
experiencing okay often the real problem
that's is like many levels below what
they're experiencing as they go about
their day okay and so we've broken a few
of those out so we've called them roles
and responsibilities discussing equity
talking about founder performance and
the last one is talking about runway how
much you got left in the bank so maybe I
mean maybe even Michael you could give
an example of one of these from you know
any of the things you've worked on sure
yeah so in the early days of justin.tv
and twich roles and responsibilities was
something that we did a very bad job at
and like one of the kind of kind of very
clear ways that I know we did a bad job
is that every single one of us started
another company and did a better job and
so like we we did a bad job we realize
that they fixed it so very specifically
we had four co-founders we were equal
co-founders and while we each sort of
knew what we were supposed to do it
wasn't extremely explicit who was
responsible for what it wasn't extremely
expressive who was possible for product
it was an extremely explicit for who was
possible for well actually you know now
I think about it it wasn't extremely
exposed to do responsible for product
hmm and like maybe that was actually the
core issue because it was explicit who
was responsible for the hardware that
was Kyle it was explicit software doing
the software that was Emmett it was
Justin show so there's a transport for
filming and you know I think was
supposed to for me responsible for
fundraising and customer support and
press and so and so forth but who
responsible the product was actually
unclear and I know that because we
fought about all the time and we changed
our minds all the time so this is
interesting so this is kind of only one
degree of separation right so you were
just like bickering about product in
particular yeah yeah and it came across
in these absurd ways Justin I had a
three-day debate about
with the background color of the website
Justin wanted black and I wanted
woodgrain and are a solution instead of
actually deciding who should had product
was to allow the user to select
different background yeah and that's
exactly like what a coach would help
with because they have laser vision they
can see past all the layers of criticism
and argue and stuff and they would
quickly I would guess within an an hour
probably have been able to see that that
was the actual problem which would have
saved you how much time I mean we didn't
figure it out for six years and you
didn't even figure out until like this
one moment that it was it was just
product but this is tricky though too
because so many things in startups and
in life are gray areas and so you may
not have actually known maybe black
would be better maybe a wood grain would
be better the most important things
didn't matter right like it wasn't a top
three most important thing right for our
business so like when you're arguing
about something that's not a top three
thing there's probably there's a problem
right and would you say that that that
you were able to argue about that
because you didn't have a clear goal in
mind I think it was because I cared
weirdly you know like I was the
non-technical founder and so there were
few things to care about early days
pre-launch and like this was something
that I could think about I couldn't
think about how to build our first chat
system or our first video camera but I
could have think about this and like
what we should have decided is that no
Justin's going to think about this and
Michael you're gonna think about these
other things and what's interesting when
I think back is in areas where the
responsibility was extremely clear we
actually did a good job right Kyle's
from poseable the camera he bought the
camera I meant both the website Justin
how to show like I don't I actually did
do tons of customer support
I actually organized all this press I
she knows all these sponsorships and in
those areas where there was no debate
about responsibility
like we excelled like we did better than
expected and areas where there was to be
strangely like we got to the right
solution and the screwy thing is we
didn't even debate the important part of
things right the most important product
thing about Justin deviant which is
videos on the left and chats on the
right day one video is on the left chats
on the right right
today videos on the left chats on the
right like we need we're doing even
debating that we were like debating
stupid other oh people call this bike
shedding right choosing what color paint
the bike shed yes like that's the big
debate rather than building it so so Amy
if you were Michaels coach in this
situation how would you go about walking
through like putting a stake in the
ground and saying like hey I'm Michael
I'm gonna run products or maybe not yeah
yeah that's sort of something that's on
my mind as I'm listening to you and I'm
thinking through a couple of sessions
I've had this week where you were a team
of four founders you each had your kind
of your own world although of course
they overlapped because it was early
days but you also had your own skill
sets as individuals and humans yes
hopefully those aligned with your with
what you were responsibilities however
I'm just kind of like imagining you back
in the day Michael you were you owned
what like external partnerships yeah it
was it was it was basically business the
business business stuff yes and you had
I think probably the personality to
match up very exactly and awkward they
had never built product before ever
interesting yeah but back in that date
like your skillset and stuff maybe
wasn't needed as much right and so like
there's almost this rotating set of
gears and wheels where you had all this
capacity you have the bandwidth to worry
about everything and so instead of being
able to recognize that in the moment and
put your skills to use immediately right
because you're not really needed until
all the hardware and everything like
gets into place where you can sell it or
whatever like I forget your question
Craig but as your coach I would have
been able to recognize that and been
like what is the most impactful thing
that you with your skill set and your
particular piece of the pie can like how
can you impact the bottom line right now
too
knowing that right now yeah what you
want to do isn't important and that's
fine and that's good like not all
cylinders need to be firing at all
moments it's funny that I think that I
certainly didn't realize that in the
first go-around and I remember in
Socialcam my second startup there were
moments where I literally was like the
most important thing I can do is be here
but not talk like but shut the [ __ ] up
because it's like we had decided what
we're building this week everyone know
they were supposed to do yeah and like
the only thing I could do in a
conversation with other people was
either waste their time or change the
plan yeah just shut up and like I ended
up I kind of realized this is just TV
but I ended up printing out this thing
was like good leadership doesn't require
being disruptive and it was like
something I always kept them back of my
mind it's like I don't need to disrupt
like at some way you just need to sit
there and build something and having
someone in your ear is not really
helpful for that and I'm curious how did
you realize that you know strangely in
the second company our authority roles
were different right so in the first
company our 30 roles were so weird it
was like Justin Emmet had done a
start-up before but they weren't really
business si and like Kyle was extremely
technical but he was doing this like
hardware thing that none of us had
expertise in and so it was all there was
this weirdness right I'm with Socialcam
even though we all had equal equity the
second time like I had been the CEO
before and they were my they'd been
employees and so I think each of us were
more there was already kind of a natural
hierarchy and I think that it was easier
for me to give things up because I
didn't feel like I was giving up power
or authority I felt like I was
delegating whereas like in the early
days it was like it was almost like
there were four CEOs it does kind of
sound like it was a free-for-all yeah it
for like teams cuz I know this is also a
common thing where you did you did have
equal equity you know you did have equal
ish sounding pie pieces yeah if in a
perfect world who would have the
to make the decision and delegate or
tell you Michael like stay in your lane
or whatever you know like I think it's
interesting right I think the story of
just abuse which is kind of is funny
because Justin started as CEO and so I
think there was probably a time in the
early days where you would argue it was
his responsibility
I'm post-launch we need to start
fundraising we switch I did this
extremely poorly but we switched and I
became CEO and I carried us through for
the next kind of five years and then
when we decide to focus in on gaming
that was kind of Emmett's expertise in
his interests so then he became the CEO
and so it's like crazier as like that
it's really kind of three embedded CEOs
right and then Kyle goes and starts Cruz
needs to see it so I'd like so I think
that at various times it was various
people's responsibilities I think by the
time he came to Emmet we were just older
and we had seen dysfunctions like man if
you see this function for long enough
and you're reasonably smart you're gonna
be like okay I think this functions not
good we should fix that
yeah but in the early days we were just
like we don't know we never worked in
companies we don't know what good looks
like right ego at the time yeah well
three out of four people were in it to
Yale so that also hey I wouldn't advise
that you mentioned equity equity is
another interesting one so Amy how does
that come out in what are the symptoms
of maybe an uneven or just like a
perceived uneven equity split how could
he is an interesting one in my
experience the way it comes out is the
person who feels as if they have less
equity than they deserve is usually the
one who calls me they call me usually at
the point at which this conversation has
boiled over such that they feel so much
resentment towards the person who has
more than they deserve or whatever that
they don't know anymore if they can even
continue on that's how it comes up in my
experience and this the and as you can
imagine you know when you feel
resentment that causes so many other
downstream effects like you can't you no
longer respect the person you are short
with them everything they do irritates
you it's sort of like pervades you every
part of your waking and sleeping life
like you have jury
and I me like deeply want to malign them
and and the solution there is just to
like have a sort of a come-to-jesus
moment with yourself and ask yourself
like should we should we renegotiate
this is it worth it can I salvage this
relationship with this person be open to
it or and or is there a price at which I
will let you know can I present a
different deal at which point I I might
walk like am i comfortable walking and
or an exploration of the past reasons
why it was okay for this person to even
find themselves in the situation at hand
and that actually to me is the more
interesting like that exploration is
more interesting to me as a coach
usually the person from the very
beginning felt as if something wasn't
quite right like when stuff what you to
and didn't say it yeah yeah and didn't
say anything and it's like and so like
why why did you it's like silence
yourself what was it about you that
didn't allow that like you to negotiate
for year own self what was what was it
about you that disallowed you from
seeing your own value and those are
patterns that often not only affect the
relationship with the co-founder but
many many other relationships and that
many other relationships and those in
that person's life so it's funny because
you talked we talked to the opposite
person mm-hmm so you talk to the person
who feels like they didn't get enough I
talked to the CEO who's usually in the
role of distributing and this was an
area where Justin was amazing from day
one and kind of set up precedent I
remember that you know in justin TV when
he and um had asked me to join up and I
was like hey III will but I want to feel
like an equal partner and he was like
great you're an equal partner yeah and I
remember being like oh like you know I
remember like that moment I felt like I
am all in yeah right and we were doing
an online reality TV show there was no
reasonable reason to be all in but I was
like well if I'm an equal partner I'm
always you know and it was interesting
because when Kyle started he had only
10% equity because he has started as
like dislike quasi employee quasi
contractor kind of thing and we were
trying to like convince him to join up
and there was a point I think three or
four
months and where Kyle was like I'd like
to be an equal co-founder and I remember
thinking to myself okay what's my model
for whether you should be and it was
like well Justin established it so amber
thinking like immediately my first
reaction was not you negotiated this you
should stick to what you negotiated I
did it out my first reaction was like
well what am it and Justin think why
he's like they're cool right you know it
was very much like open to that
conversation I think a lot of times when
I talk to CEOs now you know the reason
why I like to default II equal is it's
kind of sheets it kind of just gets rid
of this conversation right but this is
not a best fit for all circumstances but
it's hard to see is now the number one
thing that they say to me is will we
negotiated it and it's like so funny
because I'm like look as a CEO you're
thinking about your co-founders
motivation today but also five years
from now and they might not be thinking
about that and so it's not a fair
negotiation like like victory is not you
negotiated a 50 victory is like they
work really hard the whole time like you
can't let them negotiate a deal for
themselves that that's not gonna make
them work really hard and so it's so
funny I have to kill me like hey look
this isn't some business transaction
this is you know when you're coming to
get sold the company acquires you
basically puts this massive retention
you know if you do well puts a big
retention bonus that sits out there it's
called golden handcuffs and it's to keep
you there
yeah and I often tell CEOs equity is
golden handcuffs equity is what keeps
people there it's not a reward it's like
it's a it's a it's bondage in a weird
way and so like do you really want this
person to be around well if you don't
then why are they your co-founder if you
do you should probably give them a lot
it's so interesting that you say that -
because often again it's so funny I'm
talking to the opposite person like the
person who feels as if they're being
devalued and it's interesting because I
always find I have to tell them how
their behavior must be perceived by the
CEO because this person has been sitting
on this thing for years sometimes and
and it's it's like
coming out in all these random
passive-aggressive critical wave
kinematics is like we already decided on
this way the CEO often doesn't even know
where it's coming from
at all and they're like why is this
person being crazy and unreasonable and
like horrible to me and why have they
been for years like they just sort of
are often blindsided because in their
mind it's been negotiated yeah and it's
so interesting that that again like the
the people that I'm talking to they're
so they're so like filled with
resentment they can't possibly imagine
what's in that other person's mind yes
and so like again it just it it pervades
their experience um that's something
else to say but I forgot it well it's
weird to is that I think that in
situations where the equity should be
unequal like its honestly situations
where the people with lesser equity are
comfortable with that for a long period
of time mm-hmm like that is a situation
right where you know sometimes you have
companies were different founders of
many different things to the table and
so you know one founder you know with
justin.tv is like four founders who are
basically done nothing right like it
didn't feel like equal at like equal
equities felt like it made sense right
in a situation where like there's a
massive power imbalance and someone is
bringing like a lot more the table than
someone else right like you can kind of
make a case but the new the reason why
you know there's agreement on that is
because the person doesn't blow like the
person with less equity doesn't get
pissed two years from now yeah and like
if that wasn't correctly done yeah yeah
so so let's say you are in a situation
where you might be getting less equity
do you have like a good model for
playing that out in your head like in
five years am i okay with that and like
maybe that's just a simple exercise you
can do because you're basically like
ideally you would just avoid this
entirely this conversation right five
years down the line I think ideally it
requires either the either founder needs
to step up right like the CEO needs to
step up and be honest and be like hey
look I want to make sure regardless what
you think you need now yeah let's talk
about what you was going to make you
feel great five or ten years from now
let's talk about like let's imagine we
sold this company and I make more money
than
like let's really talk about that like
is that gonna feel comfortable is gonna
feel comfortable for me to get 10 times
on money than you is even for two times
more in half done it alright habit or I
think on the flip side for that and for
that you know co-founders it's not the
CEO to just be like very explicit about
hey these are the these are some of the
reasons why I believe you should have
more equity and these are some of the
reasons why I believe I should have more
I feel like it requires one person to
step up and I see a lot of situations
where neither step up that's absolutely
true the person with the least amount of
equity will never be okay with it you
know so I am always like this is always
going to be a problem until something
changes and so you might as well bite
the bullet and change it one way or
another and just like and just have the
conversation
the other interesting thing that I'm
thinking about as we're talking about
this is again the reason why some folks
sort of enter into this negotiation and
then are fine with this I mean fine and
air quotes yeah say they're fine with
the equity split even when they're not
is because they have such a difficult
time speaking to their value and saying
I am worth this because I'm amazing and
I have all the experience that you need
I also will just say that like women
often have a harder time being able to
do that and so I just want it like make
sure that that again from a coaching
perspective that that conversation like
I don't feel as if I have value erupts
not just in the equity conversation but
in many other instances too especially
for example with first-time managers
especially for example with managers who
are managing really amazing like the
c-suite and they're great like they
don't feel as if they're valid enough to
coach the other person say I'm holding
you accountable you didn't meet my
expectation in this way so again that
piece of I don't know if I have enough
if I I can't see my value you know that
that shows up in so many different ways
in my work my mind if you're the CEO on
this one I think the buck stops with you
like I think that either person could
step up but I think the CEOs
responsibility is to stop them that's
very big of yeah I think that's the plan
if the if this is a problem like this
it's the see
like this is kind of core so so many of
these things really just boiled down to
communication right like simpler more
transparent communication yes of your
intentions and your feelings yes is
there a point where there's too much
yeah like yes from a founder from a CEOs
perspective maybe if your CEO who's like
in a funk one day maybe I shouldn't be
communicating today right I don't know
what do you think I mean my first
reaction was like yes of course too much
of anything is not good everything needs
to be in balance I think in general
though people hesitate to communicate
about feelings and about difficult
topics and in that world it's never a
bad idea to over communicate because it
you can like imagine it as exercise you
need to build muscles you need to
communicate and deliver feedback to
everybody in a different way based off
of how they receive it their own life
experiences and how they're feeling in
that day and so especially when you're
first starting out like over communicate
the feedback over communicate the
difficult messages give each other
feedback on how the feedback is going
you know like but develop like a healthy
amount of hygiene there but like yeah
when you're when you're arguing when the
communication isn't productive and when
it's not even coming from a good place
too much of that is certainly not good
well that's I I think you just made it
such an amazing point in general I don't
encounter companies that are over
communicating that's very absolute ly
but I do encounter situations and I'm
thinking back my personal experience
with where it's a non-productive
communication mm-hm
yeah where it's like we're having a
fight we know we're having a fight it's
not gonna solve anything just stop
fighting yeah just don't let it go don't
keep on having the fight and I
definitely feel like when I was younger
I've somehow thought there was value in
winning the fight and I didn't realize
that like maybe every minute after 20
minutes where you're fighting you're
just reducing the value of your company
like you're just hurting everything okay
so it's just like you can't you can't
not fight at all but it's just like
there is a diminishing return for your
for your core goals yeah I know one team
who has a limit of every time they
notice they're fighting they set a timer
for two minutes and then they literally
stop the conversation and like take a
walk around the block and don't revisit
it until
next day and I hated that because I
always had I always worked things out
through talking like I couldn't I
couldn't work things out only in my head
I had to kind of have a competitive
seeing it and competitive South River
but it is and I wouldn't catch feelings
about it yeah like I like fighting but
arguing I like arguing but it's not
productive and Mini's and like and if
the other person isn't on that same
wavelength you're not helping yeah
that's kind of what I was thinking it's
it's good and totally fine that like you
need to talk things through and the more
different opinions that come at you the
better the output like the better the
final idea but if I'm coming from a
culture or a family in which like strong
opinions terrify me and I feel
overwhelmed because any conflict makes
me feel a sweat like I'm sweaty just
thinking about you Michael in your style
for example like that won't work for me
and again like your style isn't bad and
my style isn't bad they both have pros
and cons and again it's just a matter of
like knowing that and being able to talk
about it and being like and yeah having
conversations about it so you can find a
middle ground that works for everybody
yeah and it's hard to it's funny is that
it it's if I were smarter back in the
day I think I would have created no
consequence
arguing time like like I would have
separated out thinking through things
out loud from decision making and so I
and so it never would have felt like
those thinking through out loud moments
had much consequence yeah right because
like when I'm just working through my
stuff like it shouldn't be a
consequential conversation like I might
change my mind
like you know like like I'm the kind of
person it's like I strongly strongly
felt but very loosely held opinions
brand so I think later on I kind of
learned how to just like separate
decision-making from conversation and I
think knowing you Michael the one thing
that you always do really well is you in
the
whatever argumentative conversations no
just in your style you always are only
talking about the idea and so many
founding teams especially when they get
into patterns of like bad communication
hygiene are talking about the other
person okay I'm gonna pause you right
now because I know what you're saying
isn't being helpful but I know what
you're trying to say what you're trying
to say is that person beat like
co-founder when you're when you do this
with this product it my impact of the
product is that or whatever
yeah like redirect the conversation to
the actual task or not the person like
that yes because there are certain
situations we arguing because what
you're really saying is like you're not
doing your job right I've had one of
those conversations recently and I know
it was painful for the other person and
I know I just didn't have the balls to
say I don't think you're doing your job
so I had this really awkward like where
I tried to almost make it so that they
would come to that conclusion themselves
which is really stupid it's really
dangerous well but that's the next thing
we wanted to talk about so that's a
performance right yeah there you go yeah
so symptoms of feeling that someone's
underperforming yes I have been thinking
about this actually so I have come to
the conclusion that in my clients who
have performance issues of one kind or
another there's actually usually two
types of performance problems one is a
real performance problem where their
co-founder actually isn't meeting goals
and not like meeting the deadlines maybe
not showing up to work as frequently
like just sort of like they're bowing
out that is a real problem and so that's
one bucket and then the other bucket are
perceived problems of performance where
again like same thing like one person
doesn't think that the person is meeting
expectation you know and like and but
it's it's all imagined and in the first
category the real performance problems
like that is solved with having a
conversation be like hey like I noticed
that you're not meeting actual
expectation you know what's up with that
that almost always actually is about
burnout it's not about the person's
performance it's about their losing
losing business yep losing motivation
when it's a perceived problem that is
when things get a little bit trickier
because that means that goals haven't
been decided often roles and
responsibilities aren't clear
there hasn't been agreement that the
expectations and goals are even worth
pursuing and usually like so again so
performance really wide wide category of
issues in my mind they're one of two
real or perceived roles and
responsibilities so often at the core of
this like so often like if it's not
roles and responsibilities someone
should be fired because it's like in an
early stage startup like if someone
can't actually do the work right right
it's kind of like you kind of need I do
though to get the work done but it's so
rare that someone can't do the work
right like it's extremely rare so many
founders interact with this not they
can't do the work it's like we don't
know what we're doing what's the goal
did we write it down totally whose job
is it to do this in what timeline yeah
we never really wrote like oh like you
want to pull this feature did you write
a spec know do you even agree what the
feature should you know right so it's
like well how would you expect someone
to go the magical thing in your head you
know totally right and so so much of
that's roles and responsibilities and
the other thing that I think about with
performance that I think is extremely
important for CEOs is like your job is
to manage motivation like I think a lot
of times people talk about like 10x
engineers and like it's almost as if
there's this idea that like people's DNA
is different
and that's the only important factor in
their output and like I would argue that
even more important than their DNA and
like how raw smart they are is how
motivated they are and like often times
people don't talk about like you can't
change the DNA but you certainly can
change the motivation and like what I've
seen you know even here in YC is that
like it's amazing what work people will
do when they feel good about the
workplace and it's like it's just like
it's that simple like they'll blow you
away they'll do things that you didn't
even expect them to do they'll do thing
even more impressive than you could have
hoped for if you've set up an
environment where like people want to
buy in and if you set up a buy more they
don't like I don't even do the simple
things and so like I've seen far more
10x difference based on motivation than
I have based on like DNA and I've worked
with some amazing engineers there me
wrong and like they're magical but man
like you put a magical person and
they're highly motivated they're easy I
think you bring up another interesting
topic which is how especially early
stage CEOs mostly can keep their team
motivated even during the trough of
sorrow because in my mind it is a skill
like there's very few founders work who
come out of the womb with that you know
charisma and the vision setting and the
power you know it is really hard and and
do you have any I don't know I guess I
wasn't good at it I mean it's it's
interesting advising companies on it
because I just am brutally honest like
I'm just like it's gonna suck yeah like
I don't want to it's not rosy like the
fact that we even named the trough of
sorrows at YC is like just trying to be
brutally honest it's like half of not
feeling bad is expecting it yeah yeah
and like we've started telling people
you know oh when you when it's not
working it sucks and then I just started
they like and when it's working it sucks
too because like I just don't like I
just hate having the conversation with
the founders like it's taking off and I
just I feel like every day I'm getting
punched in the face I'm like oh that's
that's sorrow we didn't tell you that
but yeah that's also yeah you'll always
feel punched in the face yeah and Dalton
says something interesting which is
which I've kind of adopted as well which
is that like you have to enjoy the work
right because the emotions are always
gonna be that it's always gonna be hard
to know better like what you're doing
because if you're succeeding you feel
like crap if your family you feel like
crap so like you're not gonna stick with
it if you don't enjoy what you're doing
or at least the people you're working
with I've noticed there has to be like
some time it doesn't have to be that you
love the product doesn't you you love
the customers there be something
inherent that's not like we're gonna
make a lot of money it's most people
right something inherent in the work
that you like even if that thing changes
like this week I love the team this week
I feel more aligned with the product and
that's what's getting me out of bed you
never change but it's got to be
something anchors it has to be some work
totally regardless of whether you
succeed yeah yeah well I think it just
spirals because if you don't like if you
can't add a little levity to these
conversations you're gonna suffer yeah
it's like constant alright last one is
runway yes so what are the symptoms of
not having enough money or feeling like
you don't have enough money left that's
an interesting question for some reason
where my so this one I like as a coach I
don't get a lot of folks who's runway is
less than four or five months because
coaching is effing expensive you know
and so like right out of the bat
it's unfortunate actually it's a problem
in therapy to where the people who have
the most need are those who can't afford
the solution and I have not yet been
able to solve that problem somewhere in
my career I hope I will um but weirdly
where my brain went was in fact the the
founders who whose companies nearly died
like were to one to two months away from
dying and they like white-knuckled their
company out from the grave in order to
like live for another year or two and
yet still live everyday with that like
fear baked into every cell of their
being so and so it's sort of like runway
for me the clients that I see and then I
speak with most are those who are so
tired of living in fear and yet who's
like systems have not yet awakened to
the idea that they can have a different
life and and choose not like make
options not from that stance of fear but
rather from the stance of oh I can do
this I can now now I have the runway now
I have the growth now I have the team
the world is bright and shiny again but
for some reason I don't I don't believe
it yet yeah you're the runway problems I
see are a little different I never I I
yeah it's weird I wear like I'd probably
see three problems I see the problem
that's most society correlated with
runway is it's going to die and I feel
bad and I feel like I've let down my
employees and
investors and we kind of have a hard
conversation with the founder we're like
look your job was to try not to succeed
no one in this setup thought this was
100 percent yeah the other problem that
I see is founders who don't realize that
runways a problem right that's extremely
Commons like we have six months laughs
but everything's great like we you know
we've got twenty five people we don't
have product market favored burning all
the money in the world but everything's
great and you just like dude are you did
you really yeah and then the other kind
of folks I see I see more of are the
people who got their company out of the
grave those folks and that was just a TV
experience like those folks I'm more see
them being really good like I'm more see
them being like well if we can get
through this yeah we can do anything and
like to me those are the folks who are
exciting is like those the folks where
they're now fearless they now finally
feel in control I think as a founder you
often feel like investors control your
fate can I raise this round or not the
second that you get your company
profitable use for I think it's for the
first time you feel like a business
owner like my decisions affected the
success of my company as opposed to like
only a day if I don't convince this dude
with a bunch of money we don't succeed
and like to me that was amazing
I I actually don't think we clearly and
strategically thought about our business
for six years because we were constantly
changed a fundraising you know the
second we got profitable we were like it
was like a clear minded like okay what's
the opportunity here and it's not a
coincidence that like Socialcam and
twitch both happened after we got broke
even
yeah like before that it was just
[Music]
yeah that's where I see that like
there's so many things I'm thinking
about what you just said one of them is
yes like the founders who can dig their
company that look grave like absolutely
the best and are awesome in in my work
then there also becomes a question of
can't do I still have the energy given
given what it took me to save my company
can I still keep going yeah right yeah
so like there's a real sort of question
of is this possible still given
everything that's changed for me in the
last couple of years oh yeah and we felt
that - mm-hmm
we definitely felt that - mm-hmm yeah
how did you solve for it I don't think
we did I mean it's not a it's it's I
don't think we did I mean you just got
major factors in us in me deciding to
sell Socialcam was like it's been eight
years of struggle like someone's give me
some money like yeah yeah and they were
definitely point suggestion to be before
we a product market fit before we
figured out which that whole thing where
we got profitable like we were gonna
sell to IAC
we were gonna sell to Google like we I
think we were just like hey can we get a
win on the board and it sucks because
man I talked to founders now who say
that and like my friend thinking back
like I always tell them it's like those
wins aren't important what are you
talking about right but like when you're
in the trenches any win feels better
right anyone give me five bucks and call
it an acquisition I'll take it rather
than getting punched in the face every
day and so I probably should be a little
bit more you know sensitive to that feel
it yeah I think that's interesting that
something I was floated through my mind
this whole time was how easy it is to
see from the outside like Oh of Cour
like yeah your your life is horrible but
it can all be solved because you have
roles and responsibilities and need to
be clarified you know like it's so easy
from an outside perspective to know what
is going on and to pattern match and to
be like this is where you know you
should head and and all this stuff and
in when you're in the moment when
everything is on fire and nothing is
working it's so hard to step outside of
it and look
through like through a different but
that's just wisdom broadly right it's
the same thing as like scarcity mindset
abundance mindset like only when you're
35 years old and have some cash can you
be like dude when I was 18 man I could
have done anything when you're 50 use
like man when I was 35 man I could
shameless plug only because it's organic
and natural here that's exactly why
coaching is helpful
yeah it's because there's someone who
knows you almost better than you know
yourself and can ideally pattern match
yeah based off of their own experiences
and everything they've observed and be
able to tell you in the moment so you
don't have to look back but you know 20
years later it's funny because you know
when you and I started talking about
coaching and this object in general I
was against it completely I was just
like I was just like what you do is a
founders you suck it up like son your
job is to suck up the pain right like
Michael Jordan doesn't complain when he
has to shoot a thousand shots every day
does his job right and what's
interesting is I think that I've
realized what I actually meant I think I
didn't realize the power and kind of the
insight that PG and Jessica had was
putting companies into batches because
in reality my coaches were my batch
mates and the other people in YC and
like in reality when I needed outside
perspective I wanted support that was my
like support system and like even to
today right like those are my friends
but like you know Steve from Ratan or
I'm in from Twitter I just write like I
can go to these people and at various
different times they've had various
different experiences level of
experience right they've been ahead me
behind me and so that kind of built this
group of people that I could have kind
of coaching conversations with and their
friends do they know you over time right
it's it's it's funny that I'm only
realizing it now so I basically was like
oh yeah that coaching is [ __ ]
because I kind of have five coaches and
I do think most founders any most
founders don't do I see most founders
don't have a lot of friends or doing
startups like most founders don't have
people they know who are further along
than them indebted or not and so like in
a weird way there are some situations
where like you just don't have access to
that I think that's true and I think
also many founders so I see only
the YC founders in my practice and even
they have that community they have you
guys as partners to rely on but they
often don't have the language to even
talk about like what they're
experiencing and they like there's just
sort of like so again sort of coaching
as a supportive relationship but it's
also you learning to have a relationship
with yourself so in your own mind you
can get clear about how I'm feeling and
what my goal is for today and what my
schedule looks like and how do I treat
myself today and that's sort of like
there's a foundational level of the work
to that's important I think we were
amiss before we and to not talk about
like what are some of the tools to have
these conversations because I feel as
they're like once you're in this chain
you should have them there's still an
advantage to like having a game plan
yeah you're really good at giving people
that game time thank you Michael
yeah like in terms so you're saying
start like say there's a conversation
responsibilities conversation right you
met three people you know yeah how do we
do it how do we make it productive yeah
we've talked about this a little bit in
this podcast like one is a certain
amount of removal and objectivity like
take a step outside of your life for a
hot moment and be like this is what the
company needs like what are the roles
that are needed what are the tasks that
each role needs to be done like what is
what are ideally for this company and
where we're at how much money we have
this is what one might do and then you
sort of like plug yourself in so
essentially it's like you you build a
map based off of what's needed in the
moment and in terms of actually having
the conversation stick to the task talk
about the task don't talk about your
co-founder and what his breath smells
like and how he totally failed at you
know last week and how much you hate him
but you talk about again the task the
project the idea all that stuff and then
also speak only as much as possible only
from your own experience so use I
statements say I think I value I believe
I've noticed and your own feelings if
necessary and and do not assume anything
from your coat
like ask them questions like what do you
think what is your observation or what
is your experience Ben's considering
you've done this for you know five
months or whatever how do you approach
it when you have when you think that
maybe part of this conversation is
removing a responsibility from someone
or defining the responsibilities in a
way that you know someone's gonna be
angry about mm-hmm so how to have that
really tough conversation and you're
thinking like as the CEO like CEO needs
to happen I would my experience the CEO
initiates this conversation yeah a
little bit really sure yeah totally I
mean this is what I would suggest like
Craig I'm removing the podcast from from
your job description great I would like
be really thoughtful about how you might
take that knowing that you're probably
gonna have feelings so I'd think about
everything that I know about Craig and
what your life is like I would like be
quite explicit in terms of setting up
the meeting so I would like you know say
Craig I'd like to talk to you about this
and this like and like literally put it
on your calendar that is different than
me just catching you in the middle of
our workspace anything I definitely have
clients who have done stuff like that
got a second being explicit and
intentional about having this
conversation and then doing a little bit
of prep and and like sitting down and
literally even writing on a script for
myself if necessary where it's like
Craig I know you've been blah blah blah
something-something podcast podcast and
unfortunately like we're going in a
different direction and so I need you
more here or you know like I'd redirect
your energy toward this but then also
explicitly say starting at this date
we're no longer gonna have the podcast
and so like again I would I would not
say I'm taking this away from you I'd
say I've been thinking and I think your
energy is best suited in this direction
and be specific again like put projects
or whatever on your plate and then I
would be explicit and say as of date
which I would said an advanced podcast
is dead but say that in much nicer words
so then really that structure is a
little bit more CEO to employee yeah
how does it change when its co-founder
to co-founder and maybe you know there's
CEO to co-founder relationships that are
hierarchical yeah
and there's certain that are kind of
like we see a lot I say it's kind of not
right looks like you have owners and
someone as a CEO title yeah like that I
don't really you tell me like in my mind
I don't know if I'd give very different
advice and I'll tell you I'll tell you
what like I'm assuming it's a we're
co-founders say we're co-founders okay
the in my mind the conversation is quite
similar but I would assume that there's
a level of trust and goodwill between us
that's foundational such that if I were
to have a difficult conversation and say
you know my opinion is that we should
move away from the podcast in order to
do something else you would not take
offense and you would want to ask me
some questions to clarify and then again
assuming trust in goodwill like you
would be okay with this experiment
assuming that it you know it's just an
experiment but it doesn't regret our
lease job a great point that's why the
department in you do how do you know in
that situation where it's like I think
like I've had those conversations where
the person has kind of gotten it right
like you kind of make the case and the
person you know sometimes like having
the conversation is me I like thinking
about the conversations were people than
having it definitely other side is like
yeah the podcast hasn't been going well
like well they've been avoiding it -
exactly yeah but there are other
situations where like Craig would say
well no the podcast has ten thousand
listeners every week like this is
important part of our brand this part of
our strategy mm-hmm
like like you know there are other
situations where it's actually more of a
questions so yeah like my response to
that is ideally you would already have
roles and responsibilities outlines you
know which I would think that would
solve whatever this hypothetical
question is where like Craig would get
to decide what the social like what
we're doing socially and like would have
probably cleared that in advance you
know we're all in alignment because it
because it's directly linked to whatever
our company goals yeah it's a really
good point yeah to me it kind of sounds
like it's possible the metric changed
yeah or if you didn't have a metric in
the beginning then you messed up exactly
right right but if it was neither in
then interest a matter of taste then it
gets really tricky yeah
to me like if you've assigned roles and
responsibilities you shouldn't write
like if the role responsibility is like
Craig is figuring out the social media
strategy yeah right then like like
either you trust him to do it yeah and
then it's his test that runs the show
yep or you don't and you're moving the
role you're rooming responsibility
that's exactly right yeah because you're
you and before you we realize this you
would be micromanaging Craig and of
course Craig wouldn't take well today
it's not your place to be doing that
anyway that's a really good point and
this is that I actually see that dynamic
all of the time the other thing I would
say in regards is something you said a
while back is say you do whatever remove
podcast from Craig's so sorry about your
life Craig but you can tell that Craig
has like weird crinkly feelings about it
but nobody that like he's not saying
anything
yeah always asked like how are you
feeling like how is it I know how much
time and effort you spent on the podcast
I know it was like near and dear to your
heart like I'm I don't want to be the
bad guy but like tell me you know tell
me what's up you know see you kind of
like put your friend and colleague hat
back on you check in with them
personally yeah and give them an
opportunity to share however they felt
about how you were right and so that
gets all the like creepy crawlies out of
the closet and you can like smash them
together and then you can like walk out
of the door you know and apologize
whatever take care of the feelings and
get back to work it's funny because even
in this example we kind of illustrate
what happens in a start-up where it's
like we almost pre assumed there weren't
roles responsible yeah yeah like the
solution was being quite about that
upfront I feel like that conversation is
a more collaborative conversation though
who what our roles responsibilities are
is a more collaborative founder
conversation right and again ideally
each person's role and responsibility is
linked back to that company-wide metric
and a goal like and their skills and
their skills exactly a much more of a
yeah like you said before it's a
dispassionate like resource skill
matching absolutely power distribution
right and also knowing that maybe every
six to eight months that conversation
needs to be a rehan again just given
especially in the early days probably
before
seed is change things change yeah
totally agree no it's good not to
surprise people so I think that was the
one you wanted to get to right Oh
yeah so there's there's one question
from a Jeannie McCallister right Jeannie
McCallister asks what's the single most
important piece of advice you can give a
founder my single most important piece
of advice that I would give to any
founders is to be brave and that means
to start having difficult conversations
if they're on your mind you know you
know you need to have them and that also
could mean being brave by getting into
therapy and like learning to sit with
yourself and the creepy-crawlies of your
own mind and your own feeling space
actually takes a lot of courage and not
enough people do it all so Jeannie
McCallister is my mom so thank you mom
you know mine is one that originally
comes from PG and Trevor to the founders
of YC where they would call us every
week and say launch and it was funny
because I was the single non-technical
founder of justin.tv and I was just like
I can't there's I can't press the button
till I don't even know where the button
is do you fit and they were just common
like why haven't you launched yet and
it's so funny because there is so much
there's so much you can talk about and
[ __ ] about and argue about
pre-launch that's just like after you've
launched it's like a yes completely out
of order
and like the longer you spend in that
pre-launch and if you are dysfunctional
the longer you spend in the pre-launch
like the more like it's a perfect
environment for dysfunction to grow yeah
whereas like once you're launched and
you have conceited customers yelling at
you it's a lot more clarifying like what
you should be talking about what you
shouldn't be talking about we didn't
talk about the background on justin.tv
ever again after so yeah like it's some
ways what's so funny is that like you
don't have to do any of these things to
be successful like a lot of the
successful companies we know are in
various degrees broken absolutely yeah
there's just like these are kind of
hints and tricks that help me grease the
skids a little but the reality is like
the bigger thing is like did you launch
your product do you care about the
problem is a product solving the problem
the customer and like I hate this one of
the best quotes on culture I've ever
heard and it's just it's sucky from like
a
intellectual place but it's really true
is that like it's all easier to have
great culture when the products working
and the companies succeeding yeah like
you just started instead of starting at
addy and having a wickiup you're
starting to be plus like this is a lot
easier cool all right well thanks so
much guys these guys thanks having me
you